parce que j'ai l'intention de parler
c'est de la souveraineté donc de
déterminer d'expliquer d'avoir une
approche didactique une approche
pédagogique parce que le référendum
c'est une modalité la souveraineté c'est
l'essentiel chouette heures un chef qui
va être ton rassembleur un chef qui veut
justement faire le nécessaire pour que
le québec devienne un pays
alors c'est parti le sixième candidat
est le plus important pierre karl
péladeau s'est lancé dans la course à la
direction du parti québécois et sa
priorité vous venez l'entente est sans
équivoque c'est la souveraineté alors
quels sont ses atouts ses défis daniel
tâche à michel bonsoir
donc vous l'avez entendu aussi pierre
karl péladeau affirme notamment qu'il va
être un chef ou qu'il veut être un chef
rassembleur est ce qu'il a ce qu'il faut
daniel écouter parti québécois est pas
facile à
ressentir dans l'adn parti québécois
juste souhaite bonne chance mais oui de
tous les candidats connus et je pense
bien qu'on les connaît tous maintenant
les 6 il est de loin celui qui peut
redresser ce parti le relancer ce ne
sera pas facile la course à la direction
sera difficile le parti québécois part
de loin le bloc québécois a quasiment
été éliminé il ya trois ans le pq se
retrouvaient à 25 ans sera à 2,2 de vote
lors de la dernière élection 8% dans les
villes ancien bastion de jean garraud
donc la côte est très longue à remonter
à yaya cadre que fixe monsieur parizeau
celui de la souveraineté c'est très
légitime ça va plaire à tous les
souverainistes
pado qu'est ce que j'écris en prison
à l'intérieur de cette souveraineté de
ce cadre de la souveraineté qui est très
légitime
il va falloir poser des gestes bien
précis à moi je peux pas imaginer karl
péladeau être content des finances
publiques jamais il aurait permis que
son empire quebecor soit administré
comme les
bons d'achat sur la forme il a fait
cette annonce le jour où on votait à
québec sur une motion de censure
présentée par le parti québécois est-ce
qu'il faut se surprendre pas du tout
écouter
pierre karl péladeau et est habitué à
faire ce qu'il veut être le maître de
son destin je pense pas que
ils seraient des routes et par cela
certes c'était important mais ils
étaient 900 falaq le contraste un peu
ici en ontario dogues fourrure deux
frères de rob ford était fait une
conférence de presse pour déclarer qu'il
ne faut pas se présenter au leadership
du parti conservateur et c'est en
ontario monsieur péladeau se met devant
les étudiants très relax très naturelle
et ils laissent tomber quand une
question que oui va chercher ses papiers
de nomination c'était classique je
trouvais je pense qu'il est très à
l'aise ici que dans les sondages il mène
dans les sondages à l'interné et aussi
avec la population alors il est très
confiant je pense et ça c'est pour cette
raison qu'il a fait aujourd'hui michel
vous l'avez suivi à la trace aujourd'hui
alors il dit que son seul objectif c'est
la souveraineté est ce que c'est un bon
départ pour lui est ce que c'est aussi
au diapason de ce que pense la
population
dans la perspective du leadership c'est
exactement ce qu'il fallait dire la
souveraineté c'est ce qui unit les
souverainistes le au delà de leurs
divergences entre la gauche la droite le
centre
pour ça ça excellent stone message pour
ce qui est de la population bain tout le
monde connaît les sondages il est clair
qu actuellement les québécois sont pas
prêts à voter oui mais c'est précisément
pour ça que les péquistes sont si
entiché de monsieur péladeau ils se
disent y en a un qui est capable de
faire en sorte que les québécois
surmonte l'insécurité économique qui
demeure je pense le principal obstacle à
la souveraineté bas c'est bien pierre
karl péladeau et aujourd'hui il le dit
de façon très très clairs à l'université
de montréal et dit moi je veux faire la
démonstration qu'avec la souveraineté
les québécois peuvent et vont s'enrichir
alors c'est le massage et c'est pour ça
que les péquistes veulent de lui bon
alors reprenons un peu on en a parlé
beaucoup au cours de la semaine en
apprenant pas ce soir quelles sont ses
plus grands atouts daniel écoutez c'est
un homme d'affaires c'est un homme
d'affaires crédible il a réussi c'est
une tête de cochon tout le monde qui ont
travaillé de près ou de loin aux et bien
c'est l'expression vous connaissez tous
et qui ont travaillé de près ou de loin
avec lui savent qu'on ne faut pas lui
marcher sur les pieds savent qu'ils ne
reculent pas facilement qui de très bons
arguments pour le convaincre
il sait où il veut aller c'est peut-être
pas toujours la bonne direction mais lui
sait exactement où il s'en va et il va y
aller que ça plaise ou pas aux membres
de son parti que ça plaise ou pas à la
ftq à la frange de purs et durs du parti
québécois il va y aller il va peut-être
devoir avaler un certain nombre de
couleuvres d'ici le congrès à la
direction pour plaire à cette frange pur
et dur pour plaire à la ftq mais une
fois qu'il sera élu chef de parti
québécois je pense qu'on va découvrir un
nouveau pierre karl péladeau cynique ce
que vous dites
c'est normal c'est la politique belle et
vous ai fait un peu cynique ip pierre
quebecor pierre karl péladeau beau
changer carrément il va te faire un
certain nombre d'ajustements parce que
la politique c'est un jeu qui est pas
toujours facile à jouer il est ce qu'il
est je pense pas qu'il va changer pierre
tournon jamais changé stephen harper
aussi c'est une tête de cochon qui sait
où il s'en voit qu'ils voient
directement sans faire de compromis j'ai
l'impression il me rend peut-être pas ma
comparaison avec un peu mais j'ai
l'impression que la double fonctionne
exactement de la même façon c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'il va être le vrai
péladeau et palau péladeau qui se
présente présentement qui parlent contre
l'austérité qui essaie d'aller un peu
plus à gauche pour plaire aux gens
parlaient de ph potentiel sur le fleuve
saint laurent aujourd'hui devant les
étudiants j'en croyais pas mes oreilles
mais en tout cas je quand tu étais
scolaire ou si c'est ça oui écoute plein
de choses que l'opé l'habitude péladeau
que je connaissais quand j'étais à
l'institut fraser ne parlait pas alors
on va voir ce qu'il oeuvrait monsieur
péladeau mais certainement je pense
qu'il apporte une certaine confiance au
poste et aussi le fait que bon il est il
peut gagner je pense que c'est sale et
piqué sont fatigués de perdre ils ne
veulent pas être dans une position comme
la dernière fois ils veulent gagner et
c'est seul son plus grand atout je pense
qu'ils apportent au mouvement est le
grand défi mais celle s'cusez moi le
grand défi de péladeau c'est que si
jamais fait dépouilleurs réussi son
opération assainissement des finances
publiques il va se retrouver dans une
situation où ce serait très difficile de
battre fédé couillard et 2 il devra lui
aussi montré qu'il est capable de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent mais
aujourd'hui il a il a dit que c'est très
brutal la façon dont on faisait tous ça
il ya parler d'eux y'a dit que c'était
doctrinaire mais michel sur ces défis
donc ils attendent parce que quand même
c'est la semaine dernière il faut qu'ils
apprennent à la dure un peu le métier de
politicien il doit se définir aussi
expliqué
je voudrais plutôt qu'ils devraient qui
doit se redéfinir
actuellement le principal obstacle je
pense qu'ils se posent à lui au pq
cesser son image l'a22 capitaliste sans
coeur et sans scrupules c'est pour ça
que la ftq a évoqué la possibilité de
faire carrément campagne contre lui et
la souveraineté c'est très beau mais
monsieur péladeau disait cet après midi
que bon le référendum c'est rien qu'une
modalité mais il a dit aussi qu'avant la
d'ici la prochaine élection on saurait
si les chefs du pq s'il y aura ou non un
référendum dans le premier mandat ça
veut dire qu'ils pourraient ne pas y en
avoir ça veut dire que monsieur péladeau
gouvernerait au québec province et à
partir de ce moment là les gens vont
vouloir savoir si et à gauche ou à
droite qu'est ce qu'il faut faire avec
le privé en santé qu'est ce qui va faire
par exemple je suis convaincu que les
centrales syndicales ont dû demander
écouter la réforme du code du travail on
parle de de moderniser la loi anti scab
que monsieur péladeau largement utilisés
pendant ces conflits il va falloir
qu'ils nous disent comment il va
gouverner au delà de la souveraineté
parce qu'elle pourrait bien ne pas
arriver oui justement vous disais est ce
qu'il est de gauche et ce qu'il est de
droite c'est aujourd'hui c'est un peu
difficile de savoir d'achat oui et je
pense que c'est exactement ce qu'il veut
à écoute c'est vrai qu'il ya une
opposition alors il doit s'opposer au
projet du gouvernement telle
augmentation des frais de garderie mais
quand même je pense qu'il va jouer ce
jeu là parce que justement il veut
rassurer les militants du parti
québécois qui n'est pas le grand méchant
capitaliste et je pense que sa vision
plus économe fort économiquement
voeckler a une grande partie du centre
et aussi certaines portions de la gauche
je voudrais tu la connaître sa vision de
l'économie parce que par exemple
l'austérité là ils dénoncent la
titularité y dénoncer l'austérité mais
quand on lui dit oui mais monsieur
péladeau est ce que vous êtes vous
suggérer de reporter le déficit zéro à
plus tard alors il dit plus rien ce
ballet va falloir voir alors beaucoup
plus précis on n'a pas besoin d'aller si
vite que ça que l'on peut pas je dire
que la dette c'est peut-être pas
nécessaire de tout il va dire plusieurs
choses si le congrès à la direction pour
ne pas pour ne pas déplaire bon aux gens
qui sont pas d'accord avec lui sauf que
si vous regardez les débats qui animent
les cinq candidats avant lui ça tourne
autour de quad mêmes vieux débat qui
fait le pq depuis rené lévesque en 1970
il sait que son identité l'environnement
à tous crins a rien sur les ressources
naturelles rien sur l'assainissement des
finances publiques c'est comme si ces
candidats là vivait dans un monde qui
n'est pas celui de l'ensemble de la
population du québec c'est à pierre karl
péladeau de brasser cette cage l'a pas
facile à faire dans le parti québécois
il risque de devoir regarder derrière
lui très souvent mais c'est de ce sont
des débats incontournables michel
justement à partir d'aujourd'hui il se
lance donc à ce qu'il devient la cible
dans cette course a qu à quoi il faut
s'attendre
bayou il est déjà d'une certaine façon
tout le monde sait que c'est lui qui est
le grand favori je m'attends pas à une
course salle à moins qu'ils aient des
révélations scabreuses le cocon qu'on
peut vraiment pas prévoir mais d'une
part c'est le favori il s'agit pas de
lescun été à tel point qu'ils ne soient
plus présentable s'il est élu et d'autre
part c'est contre-productif de frapper
en bas de la ceinture monsieur bachand
pourrez vous en parler ça ne pas payer
du tout associé philippe couillard
à partir du rang de la console le chef
libéral mais il va devoir répondre à des
questions aujourd'hui je voyais monsieur
rainville qui commençait des voix mais
sur la charte la pierre carles alors
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent et qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent du port de signes
religieux pour les employés de l'état y
la fois qu'ils soient précis pour juste
dire la laïcité c'est une belle chose la
même chose par exemple la loi 101 au
cégep les pauvres où il compte il ya
beaucoup de sujets de points très précis
où il va devoir dire quelque chose
évidemment daniel les attentes sont
toujours très élevés quand on est le
meneur et la course va être longue c'est
une très longue course et on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une surprise moi aussi je suis
d'accord avec michel il part largement
favori et à moins et à moins de deux
révélations catastrophe et qui devrait
gagner cette course là mais c'est une
très longue course appelée boudreau
craquer rappelez-vous stéphane dion
parti québécois n'est pas à l'abri de
surprises non plus à il y aura beaucoup
de questions qui seront posées assure
sur l' empire de monsieur péladeau il va
faire quoi il a répété aujourd'hui que
ce sera une fille du 600 droit de regard
à mais s'il perd la course et la
direction est ce qui va reprendre ses
billes retourner chez lui faire ses
affaires à il va falloir que il va
falloir qu'ils soient très vigilants
parce que ce serait trop facile bon
évidemment dans le reste du canada ça va
faire réagir ça cesse ah oui cette
candidature
ah oui absolument écoute c'est c'est
quelque chose qui va brasser les cartes
non seulement au québec mais aussi à
ottawa pour l'un et des c'est clair que
ça pose un grand dilemme si monsieur
péladeau prend la tête du pq le pq
redevient fort la question souverainiste
revient comment ce que monsieur mulcair
clay à son électorat qui est aussi
nationaliste et en même temps le reste
du canada pour monsieur europe 1 c'est
presque une petite trahison personnel
parce que monsieur péladeau et madame
sneijder ils les ont reçus à 20,4
sociaux qu'ils étaient amis et on pense
semble-t-il peut-être monsieur péladeau
cherchait cultiver cette amitié là avec
des visions d'affaires en tête
parce que on sait tous que les intérêts
dans le monde des télécommunications ou
avoir des décisions favori favorable
c'est toujours une bonne chose alors
messieurs harper je pense que toutes les
affaires que monsieur péladeau a fait
elle se lance en politique pour le pq
ses traits se laisse un goût très amer
et ça va être aussi pour lui un problème
dans le reste du canada si monsieur
péladeau commence à faire campagne pour
la séparation quoi michèle ouimet il
c'est sûr que monsieur péladeau var
polarisé toute la question avec eux la
souveraineté va redevenir une
possibilité disons je pense que pour
monsieur mot rigueur ça va être
effectivement catastrophique dans la
mesure où il est pour le 50 +1 et
lassana il va devenir suspect je pense
que monsieur harper est en mesure après
monsieur trudeau c'est trudeau qui va
être avantagé par sa messieurs après pas
parce que monsieur harper est trop mou
sur une taie canadienne mais tout le
monde sait qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'assises au québec tandis que monsieur
trudeau lui on peut lui reprocher toutes
sortes de choses mais il va faire élire
des députés au québec est plus populaire
que monsieur harper au québec et je
pense qu'il reste d'être perçu comme
quelqu'un qui est plus en mesure de
dissuader les québécois de se tourner
vers la souveraineté que monsieur a eu
le mot de la fin chose certaine je ne
pense pas que pierre karl péladeau va
faire campagne alors en octobre prochain
s'il était du chef du parti québécois au
côté du bloc québécois parce que ce
qu'il a dit il ya quelques jours et fait
assez bien sa pensée et ce sera peut
être l'alliée principale de mario
beaulieu alors c'est intéressant la
semaine prochaine on aurait pu parler
évidemment là tout ce qui se passe ici
le grand chambreur chambardement on aura
une mise à jour économique la semaine
prochaine on s'en reparle on se retrouve
pour ça merci beaucoup à vous trois